j'avais envie qu on a rendez vous avec
carl lewis
et moi c'est votre locataire oui
maldini vous l'ouvrez un appartement ici
dans dantagnan couche
et c'est à vous
oui
moi j'aime bien les femmes ont échoué
voilà on a une âme
il sympa sur le problème c'est qu'il
fait des films avec bernard henri lévy
quoi ça ça pour quoi 1 pourquoi je sais
pas vous croyez sa mère est très sympa
mais je viens de chercher l'on doit
aller dans une boîte de partouzes
normalement avec sociaux
c'est vrai on a rendez vous renier ses
cartes
massive de ces cartes axa qui l'a mise
aux normes a dit au rez-de-chaussée
car
c'est là que tu es la visite pour toi
un
féticheur êtes saisis est donc voilà
bombe à bord rien de chercher pour la
boîte de partout cela tient
pas
tout
je vous laisse
car
tu
quoi ces modes de participation chez ma
mère mon père
à huit fois c'est au dessus voilà je
vais te présenter moment bien
non mais attends je vais pas te déranger
donc non mais bien les
alors vous êtes devenu une star avec
votre libre attentes et moi un peu mais
vous avez fait quoi comme émission
devant j'ai fait la première c'était
chez delarue ouais et puis quand tu es
moi quand ce sujet est merveilleux pour
notre famille c'était comment gagner 30
mai ont peu ou pas du tout à ça il nous
a dit qu'après c'est l humour est il une
affaire de famille là j'ai pas pu
refuser c'est vrai j'ai dit mais oui
mais écouter chez nous mon frère yves et
moi déjà alors j'ai dit avant la guerre
alors il me dit qu'elle guerre va quand
même pas celle de 14,10 la prochaine
alors bon on a commencé à rire comme ça
et puis après j'ai dit les fils ont sucé
avec à la table familiale avec le
management
n'est pas passé loin
mauvais esprit mais moi aussi je vous
étiez paca je suis terriblement cocaïne
vous voulez toujours solide en 10 watts
c'est pour ça qu'on est passé en fait ce
soir parce que c'est un amateur regarde
jamais voulu venir
s'est cru obligé de partir alors il m'a
dit pas sûr à ma mère on sait jamais si
tu veux
mais vous savez sur ma bio de remise à
gré c'est pour mon livre j'ai ouï je
connaisse les problèmes ça c'est le
réflexe promotionnelle de la rue donc
déjà pas payer de la rue pour y aller
tuer tout ce qui vient du raid mais
caché
mais je suis pas là et puis alors après
je m'étais morandini oui alors quand ils
m'ont vu à la dhr ils ont absolument
voulu que j'aille à la une
ça qu'on
veut comme ophélie winter alors je suis
allé chez morandini et alors il a
commencé par me poser la question parce
que dans mon livre un certain endroit je
disais que j'avais bien rire la vieille
dame indigne savait alors il a dit m
êtes vous une vieille dame indigne alors
j'ai dit vieille mais pas du tout je
suis plus jeune que vous citerai se
trouve beau dame je suis pas d'adamov à
regarder moi dimensionnelle suivante par
le tailleur suivant joie il faut
s'assumer non mais on vient d'apprendre
qu'ils rient de ce qu'on aime pas du
tout dépend de vous non mais j'ai pas en
demandant son salut à toi + moi non plus
alors après un deal j'ai dit bah écoutez
c'est à vous d'en juger mais où je l' ai
toujours été où je ne suis pas plus si
vous vous appelez s'éclater rigoler tout
ça bon bah 70 printemps pourquoi pas
mais moi j'ai toujours rigoler dans ma
vie malgré les difficultés
dur alors j'ai écrit ce bouquin parce
que justement la vie elle est très dure
pour tous n'attendent et d'aveux donc
vous fait la promo c'est parfait mais
moi savoir d'abord tout ce que vous avez
vécu l'aller les césars par exemple
cette année avec un volume en mettant
mes enfants m'a vite vous pensez si je
suis content je savais tout seul avec
karl non
mais oui
alors nous devons c'était vous cette
année tout d'un coup tu es c'était bien
c'était un peu longuet savez quand ils
disent merci beaucoup à l'équipe parce
que c'est plus long que la télévision
encore qu'on peut pas se lever pour
aller prendre une bière au frigo ouvert
marqué à la rigueur on peut les faire
pipi avec un discrètement surmonter ou
boire une bière est alors non moi si
vous voulez je m'amusais bien parce que
d'ailleurs j'ai un bon naturel je
m'abuse de tous il allait aux sept d'or
aussi ah bah oui j'ai talent et la prime
d'apport mais oui il allait bien j'étais
rincé d'or ton costume tâche et parce
qu'on avait lancé on avait des
serpentins là qui sortait du tout
moi je préfère profiter ta maman de ta
célébrité celle ci s'en sort très bien
oui c'est possible que nous avons
toujours partagé tout anne laure le sait
parce qu avant son mariage elle a déjà
été six ans dans le cercle familial
avant de se marier
vraiment tous rencontrés thèmes viennent
de partout
c'est méconnaître et nous nous sommes
accueillants tous nous étions très
heureux d'accueillir anne-laure parce
que remarquer c'est dans la lutte est
donc voici et ses vins c'est pas bien
c'est très personnel dont on parle
d'autre chose et habitées palau les îles
revenons nous revenions à ta promotion
alors tu as fait j'en ai des analyses
c'est vrai oui merci
vous été gêné dans ma vie aussi mais on
a été invité et à la recette c'est l
imposture alors il a commencé en disant
nous sommes tous des apostats alors je
vais écouter parler pouvoir
parler pour vous me parlez pas pour toi
et à l'heure matt carle a dit dans des
faits ma mère n'est pas du tout pour ça
et alors on a commencé là dessus et puis
c'est vrai qu'il y avait plein d'
imposteur parce qu'il y avait des
prêtres vous savez qui critiquent l
vatican
aucun joueur autonome au large et animer
son émission était ravie mais si
possible à cette drogue assez difficile
de se lancer la karma theron et guerbert
heureusement que tu nous lis pas ce
qu'on allait justement patients
c'est la salle en salle
moi je n'ai pas vu le
jour à sion il fait ces ricains et on va
en parler de cas près parce qu'il ya
quand même un truc qui est bizarre c'est
que vos votes l'x et c'est extrêmement
positif disons et très joyeux réellement
joyeux page et c est sans
nuance je dirais péjorative et karl lui
alors il passe son temps à faire des
choses un peu un peu cynique un peu
comment vous pouvez comment vous pouvez
le rythme le reconnaître ce quart
d'heure où les chiens
si vous voyez beaucoup mais quand même
ça donc incomplète je vais vous dire
pourquoi parceque il a une nature qui
est différente de la mienne il a une
façon de s'exprimer différente de la
mienne les d'une génération différente
parce que c'est mon petit dernier il est
venu
vous demander tout
on s'est parlé n'y a
pas ce que dans ce film est ce que tu
embrasses arielle dombasle je ne parle
pas du film va être que tombera ça n'est
pas pour parler que tu embrasses g
désordre très strictes je ne doive
bernard maintenant d'état
bernois bernhard pulver mabisaba va bien
bâle un temps qu'une
gifle et quand tu veux ouais commencé de
le dire pour l'instant un prêtre mais
parce que je repars demain parce que
senna rouler des scènes à refaire j'ai
un rôle exponentielle mais tu fais quoi
dans la vie c'est ça ouais un producteur
tu fais un producteur ouais tu connais
pas à toi producteurs je suis le
meilleur producteur du monde et
travaille sur une chaîne rien n'est pas
meilleure du monde
festival de cannes est obligé en même
temps
faut rien dire sur le film les chtis
bien sur laquelle surfe sur jeudi à
temps bouge pas je ne bouge pas mais non
je prends de mettre en batterie je
disais que ses gentils parce qu'il est
rentré pour me faire la promotion avec
moi c'est super bien et il repart parce
que si vous aimez vous voyez tué au
moins tous les 15 jours au système
j'ai bien plus ou
non mais attendez avec tout mais si
c'est comme ça je vois d'asile et et je
vois olivier chaque fois que et éric lui
vit à la maison mais on s'aime tout ça
existe encore ça des gens qui s'aiment
pas ce que tu crois toi on va y aller en
lan vo on peut vous l'enlevez alors est
ce que je peux donner la permission
c'est toi qui décide
quoi monsieur par tous
c'est à lui de juger a manqué des signes
il est gentil et calme
oui très il donne des bonnes et rennes
cannes avec
celui qu'elle vit ça la met enfin vous
ne savez pas visés sont pourtant grande
nos amis les poubelles c'est vous qui
avez marqué ça
s'est un peu poète bin oui et non car il
vous suffit de pas trop de blé alors
oui
hamon
non ça je peux pas d'accord avec le
prénom est à poney ou qu'ils gagnent et
bernard
sa fille nahla
on ne m'a jamais donné un sentiment
sincère ah ben oui si je voulais je vous
voulez quelque chose
lui que j'ai pris
ça je suis très déçu heures et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux